this morning on the dish Timothy
Hollingsworth had humble beginnings in
the food industry born in Texas and
raised in central California his first
restaurant job was as a dishwasher but
he rose through the ranks and to the
highest heights
he became the chef de cuisine at Thomas
Keller's world-renowned French Laundry
and won the James Beard Award for rising
star chef he eventually stepped out on
his own in Los Angeles where his odium
serves vibrant rustic dishes flavored
with the influence of his worldwide
travels Timothy Hollingsworth good
morning welcome to the dish thank you
for having me tell us what's on this
great table yeah we have cauliflower
roasted with almonds capers and grapes
butternut squash with a coffee glaze in
homemade ricotta on far in there you
have a fig and burrata tart with a
little onion jam on the bottom and this
is one of our most famous dishes it's a
herb roasted chicken with shishitos and
soy glaze with tomatoes and Aleppo
seasoned potatoes and then of course for
dessert we have a milfoil
with hazelnuts and vanilla cream of
course all right chef so let's start at
the very beginning humble roots in the
south big family where'd you learn to
love food I think I learned to love food
around the table you know my family that
was a one time that my family was all
together and sitting around the table
and and eating and we have a very close
family still today and I think that's
why I have such a love and care for it
hmm but what I was really struck by in
your story is that when you grew up and
you started out in Texas yeah I moved to
California but but at age 19 I think it
was you flew yourself to New York yeah
there's my first time on an airplane I
flew myself to New York I wanted to go
check out the culinary school at the CIA
in Hyde Park
I ate Atlas circ checked out the
culinary circle Andheri Institute for a
week came back down ada do cost well at
the Attucks what were you telling
yourself at this point honest honest I
don't want to be a chef you know any did
you go from never having been on an
airplane to lucilla Cirque and do cops I
mean that's just that's a big grand
ambitions yes little ignorant too naive
and being young and you know I don't
know amazing why did Thomas Keller
choose you yeah I think he chose me to
get me off his back a little bit
I called and I called him finally he he
said okay come try out and then okay I
winner tried out and then I called I
called I called and then I called it
called and he finally said okay come did
you not let I'm for when I read you
literally went to his with your resume
to the restaurant on a night you knew
he'd be there
I called multiple times to make sure
that he was going to be in the
restaurant that night and I would be
able to turn in my resume to him what
did you learn from him at per se
obviously yeah but I opened a per se but
I learned the the work ethic that he had
the the legacy that he tries to build
the love that he has for the the
industry that we're in is pretty
impeccable and just as detail he's so
detail-oriented every detail matters
yeah you stayed at French Laundry for
thirteen years yes that's a long time in
any restaurant yeah but I think you know
you when you're when you're you know
somewhat comfortable in an environment
you're able to learn more I spent a lot
of years traveling you know I'd work and
then we'd have two weeks off during
those two weeks off I'd go and travel to
France and maybe work for a couple weeks
or England and work for a couple weeks
in other people's restaurants and come
back and apply that knowledge at the
French Laundry and when we talk about
otm your restaurant in LA it says we
know that you've woven in taste from
around the world what are they what if
what have you held on to I mean I think
it's American food I think it's American
food at its finest America's as a you
know melting pot of so many different
cultures that we draw influence from
from who we are Los Angeles there's like
how many different ethnicities and
different cultures and different cities
for different people and you know that's
that's really what American food is all
about American food is about the whole
world it is chef as I asked you to sign
this dish as it's custom here on this
segment I'll ask you the question we
always pose which is if you could share
this meal with anyone past or present
who would it be well that's a tough
question
Elaine Chapelle I think he's one of the
chef's that uh that I read about as a
young cook and having his philosophy
about around food was was so inspiring
and I would have loved it and met him I
would have loved to work for him well
well maybe maybe up in the sky a bounty
chef Timothy Hollingsworth thanks for
your time and congrats on every thank
you and for more on chef Hollingsworth
and the dish head to our website at CBS
this morning dot-com